والله ماشيين من حالفه القاهره جوه هتمشوا
مصر هنمشي مصر
والله
والله قاعدين لكن المشكله
في الدكاكين بقى في العيش بقى في اي حاجه
حتى الاندومي الحاجه البسيطه
في الشارع من بيتنا الثاني داخل على شقتي
الرصاصية عيني سكينه الدعامه بنص الحله
الرصاص تحت العين يعني
النزول حاليا هذه البساط السفريه تتجه
لمناطق مختلفه من
السودان يعني من الولايات وهذا بس تحديدا
يتجه الى القاهره معي هذا الشاب مرحبا
وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله شكلك مو مسافرين
انت اول حاجه
التموينيه اغراض
عندي ناس مسافرين من الخرطوم فالاضاءه
يعني معلومه يعني تعلمونها جيدا كيف
الاوضاع في السودان
عدم توفر مراكز تجاريه عدم توفر خبز يعني
حتى اذا فتح
حصلت على المواد الغذائيه منتظرين في واحد
بتاع دكان منتظرنه من الصباح يمكن اكثر من
خمس ساعات حتى يفتح وحتى بالنسبه للوضع
الخطا حتى لو في تفتح نص ساعه ساعه وبدون
صعوبه يعني حتى في توفير لقمه العيش في
استغلال تام من
اصحاب الباصات ان اصحاب الباصات بعشرين
لحد اسوان حاليا التذكره ب 300 يعني
بمثابه 300% او اكثر